my guest tonight is a very funny
comedian and an actress
who can be seen in the movies yesterday
and barb and star
she's also appearing in the nbc series
kenan
and her comedy special fortune feamster
sweet and salty is streaming on netflix
good god
she's doing a lot please welcome fortune
feamster how are you doing
so much right now fortune what's going
on conan i don't know what's happened
i've you know we're always trying to
work as
comedians and as actors and i happened
to film a couple of movies before the
pandemic
and then everything got shut down i
didn't work for
six months right i don't know whoever's
in charge of hollywood
mr hollywood whoever was just like that
would be me
the movie fortune that would be me i am
in charge of hollywood now i pulled the
strings
so i'll admit i decided it was your time
about three days ago and i pushed a
button
so that was me you're you're magical
i really appreciate it all this stuff
came out at one time
and it made me look a lot cooler than i
feel
uh so yeah there's a bunch of movies
that have come out in the last six
months and then i i got to do
keenan kind of came out of nowhere and
i'm doing this show for netflix it's
it's been awesome i can't complain
because i was in my pajamas for a very
long time
yeah i no it's a it's a good thing and
you mentioned keenan
uh i don't know how you shoot a show
like that during a pandemic
because that's not something you guys
shot before
you're shooting that now you've been
shooting it how do you do that how do
you work with a crew
that size and be safe
it's pretty trippy i mean they they go
to great lengths to keep everybody
safe you're tested all the time they
have zones where
you certain people can only be in the
zones where the actors are
and then once we take our mask off
because obviously we can't act with our
mask on
everybody has to have double masked face
shields it's crazy but
the biggest difference is the craft
services which i think is why i got into
acting
to begin with we're talking about
for anyone who doesn't know craft
service table i think everyone knows is
that big table
that's at every shoot everything in show
business that's just
covered with like i mean everything you
would want to eat
usually unhealthy usually kind of
unhealthy very unhealthy which seems to
be the opposite of what they want in
hollywood
uh but it's full of snacks it's it's
usually buffet like you're eating like
sliders and jalapeno poppers at like 10
a.m
and so that's the thing you look forward
to most when you shoot anything
but right now because of cobit obviously
buffets are obsolete
and they you can't touch things because
otherwise people are you know digging in
the interior
so there's like a person in like a
hazmat suit
and you go to a table and you have to
like point
at what you want which is kind of
feeling like snack
shaming because you don't want to be
that person that's like i'll have
five of this and a donut and this and so
it's
really tapered my snack game on set so
i'm always like i have cheez-its
and then you feel like you gotta ask for
like an apple
you have to you have to even if you
don't want it
and they're i'm sure like the people in
charge are like why does fortune have so
many apples in the trash can
[Laughter]
can't you pretend to eat them or give
them to somebody
yeah yeah that's true i should give them
i should give them to somebody that's
being wasteful
what's um you know in your stand up and
in your whole career
in comedy you've been a little obsessed
with chain food restaurants
and and you love to show them
the respect that you feel that they're
due
yeah it's kind of crazy to be known as
the comic that
gives a lot of love to chain restaurants
i know i can see it i mean
i i definitely i have my favorites what
do you love what are the chain
restaurants that you really love
well i talk about chili's a lot because
i grew up i grew up going there there
you know they were the fancy restaurant
that you would go to after church on
sundays
so that's always a favorite hooters is a
big part of my life
uh you know can i ask you something i'm
being honest i i
never went to a hooters because i
thought i can't go to a hooters because
i i don't want people thinking i'm going
there to look at the ladies or whatever
but i've always been intrigued how's the
food at hooters
i mean i'm a fan i love the chicken
wings that's why i
go i mean my whole family actually i was
joking about my mom she's been with us
every trip you take your mom to hooters
yeah
yeah she loved hooters and we would go
because you could get a ton of chicken
wings
and we had a big family and it was like
the perfect place
to feed a bunch of people and the food's
really good they have
tater tots um it's a dream come true for
yeah where else are you gonna get tater
tots fortune
you act like you you act like you found
a golden doubloon
they have bags of them in the freezer
aisle
you had to go to an elementary school to
get tater tots before
hooters uh introduce them now they're
everywhere but i feel like they were
ahead of their time
what's your favorite thing on the
chili's menu if one thing you could have
triple dipper i mean that's it's an
appetizer but you get to choose three
things conan
and i'm talking about boneless buffalo
wings
southwestern egg rolls and some
slaughters
the fact that i know this is very
disturbing i love that that's an
appetizer too
let's start with what's three things
let's
let's start with these three incredible
foods
also what's us would you say a south
western egg roll
oh yeah i didn't know such a thing
existed that's right
i'm opening your world to a whole new
way of living you know
first of all chili's has to love you
because you've got me talking about
chili's now
and this is a basically a free ad
neither one of us is getting paid
does chili chili's ever show you the
love for all you've done for them
i have to say they do show me a lot of
love they're like a grandmother
that sends things on like holidays
i will get like a christmas sweater out
of the blue with like
chili's all over it or they send candles
if there's like a
if it's like a president's day they send
like margaritas they're
pretty great and then after my netflix
special came out because i talked about
them on the netflix special they were
going to
uh for my show in dallas where the
headquarters is they were gonna
cater my green room with chili's
i felt like i had won an emmy it was the
[Laughter]
greatest
that actually sounds better than winning
an emmy i have to say
and and that means a sharp thing that
just gets in the way pretty quickly but
yeah that sounds
that sounds amazing it's pretty great i
wish that all of a sudden we just had a
triple dipper
come into frame right now but no we are
not getting paid for this
well once this goes out and airs i think
you and i are getting
uh you know what we want is i got ones
from arby's arby's gave me like a
special card
i can walk in and it it's like silver i
think i don't know why i think i
mentioned them on the show and they sent
me this card that i could
hold up and it gets me like a free roast
beef sandwich at arby's and the only
thing is i just felt
i just felt like i can't use that yeah
you know because i just felt bad about
going into an arby's and saying i'll
have this sandwich
and all right well uh there you go mr
o'brien oh and here's another thing
not gonna pay
this is on you buddy i wasn't gonna do
that that felt terrible
yeah i get that i get that because you
feel like you gotta at least
buy like some curly fries with it right
exactly yeah and then they gave me a
card for that so
um no you can't do it women in cards
lenny uh yeah i walk around my wallet is
just filled
with give me this for free fast food
cards
but you never use them that's no i don't
use them i know i should it's it's just
terrible but i'm always thinking why did
they give this to me
at the stage in my life where i don't
need it there was a whole stage of my
life
in my 20s uh where a fast food card
would have been very much appreciated
but
they can afford it now it's crazy uh now
i want to ask you about your mom because
i know a mom's your mom is
a a big part of your act you you talk
about her a lot
and i have a picture here of your mom
that i keep with me at all times
this picture is always with me and
oh my god yeah no i have this picture
and seriously you walk up to me on the
street and tap me on the shoulder and i
got it i'm ready to go
wow i don't know where you found that
that is
amazing you can buy these at the airport
i'm telling you
that's how big your mom's becoming
because you talk about her on your
podcast
and you've talked about her in your act
and your fans know all about your mom
your mom's becoming a bit of a bit of a
star in her own right
yeah it's crazy i i didn't set out to do
that it's just that
i learned that a lot of my material was
coming from her
and i guess from some of our bonkers
things that happened to us growing up
and i don't know like now she's got
she's definitely getting a little bit of
a big head she'll call me and she goes
i've got
fans now and i'm like calm down they're
trying to get her on social media
and i'm just trying to i'm like you only
want her in
small doses i promise you
but the stories that i end up telling
about her end up being people's
most favorite we talk about hooters like
one of the biggest stories from my
special that people resonated with was
i'd gone with her to hooters my entire
life and then all of a sudden she got a
conservative boyfriend
and i said let's go to hooters and she's
like i
have never been to
hooter
like what it's the same guy she
he came to her house one night and he
had all these magazines of like
business people and he's like my mom uh
your mom tells me that you want to be a
ceo
i'm like 14. i'm like i don't
i don't want to be a ceo and he's like
that's what
she said and my mom's like you want to
be a
ceo you said that oh my god
i don't even know what it means yeah so
i can relate to this because my mom
growing up
always wanted us to be more respectable
than we were
she was always and kind of had that same
thing of
we are the o'briens and we
what are you talking about we're the
worst people on the block
[Laughter]
yeah yeah she would always be behind
them just pointing at us
my smile and it was happy
we're perfect yeah she laughs about it
now but yeah that's where a lot of i
think my
humor comes from was just you know
those crazy moments of like how did that
happen
you know i've heard you talk about
something and and when i heard you talk
about this i was thinking
oh fortunately we we have many things in
common but this is
something we really have in common
especially during covid which is i swear
to god i have spent 80 percent of my
time
during this pandemic watching murder
documentaries
yes and um and then uh i heard you
on uh what's the murder podcast that i
heard you on you were terrific
my favorite murder my favorite murder
yeah and
and um i i was thinking
i don't know what it is about those i
will watch
all of them all they have to do is say
oh
there's a murder documentary and i don't
even ask for the details i just say well
now i know what i'm doing tonight i'm
going to watch that
it's it's incredible how much of my time
has been sent uh
spent watching these documentaries
because netflix is putting a lot of them
out now
there's like a million murder podcasts
but i'm watching these
i'm watching these murder documentaries
and i'm finding myself like
i'm so invested in this murder right but
10 minutes into
watching the documentary i'm on
wikipedia
trying to find out everything there is
to know about this
murder about the murderer and i'm like
my wife is like just watch the
documentary i'm like oh i'm watching it
but i also want to learn this at the
same time it's very bizarre i don't know
why you're multitasking you got to tell
your wife you're multitasking
you are watching the murder documentary
and you're also trying to solve the
murder at the same time using
the internet 100 100 and we watch a ton
of dateline together
now you have you have something called a
dateline packed with your wife is that
right
i do yeah we early on in our
relationship we were watching dateline
together
and you know when you're in an early
relationship you don't know if the
person that you're with
is a murderer because every date line is
like yeah the husband did it or
you know went on a date yeah so we were
watching one of those
you know date murder stories and you
kind of start
sizing each other up and kind of
wondering like are you
like are you gonna do that like where is
it
gonna land and uh so we yeah we
we kind of both at the same time just
blurted out like please don't murder me
promise me
you're not gonna murder me that's your
that's your pact is don't murder me
we literally shook hands on it you set a
very very low bar
for your relationship as long as you
don't murder me
uh i'll love you forever yeah i don't
feel
as like i'm taking as much of a risk
when i don't do the laundry
because i'm like well she's not gonna
murder me we've established that well
the other thing too
is you've probably noticed this i've
noticed this with the dateline murders
uh anytime they talk about a murder
when uh one when a husband kills the
wife or the wife kills the husband
it's always over an amount of money that
i'm sorry is ridiculously small so it's
they find out later on that well she was
gonna get the pickup truck and the
divorce
and he was gonna be out 14 you know
thousand dollars
he had only one choice murder
no just let her have the truck
yeah whatever you'll figure out but it's
always such a small
you know it was six thousand dollars or
murder
so it had to be murder i i
never understand it and and all these
people always get caught it's very rare
that people get away with it especially
nowadays with dna
and all this right now right every
dateline i
yelling at the tv just get a divorce
i don't i don't understand i don't know
it's an easier way to go
too expensive but i don't know
but then i think at the same time i
think there would then there wouldn't be
these murder shows if murder went away
and i will tell you fortune i assure you
you can get away with murder
that's all i'll say oh no yeah coz
don't don't incriminate yourself please
please i'm not saying anything else i'm
just saying
you can get away with murder okay
you can somebody should fingerprint that
guitar behind you
that's my genius it's not mine i haven't
touched it it's just there for show
yeah i want to say first of all uh
congratulations i know you got married
this year
thank you and um i have to say you have
a series of portraits from your wedding
that are i think the best wedding
portrait series i've ever seen
oh i i appreciate it was a pretty
special moment
here's it starts off and everything's
just lovely
right that's a great wedding shot then i
love
this you sense trouble
something's coming right it's coming
your way
but we don't know what it is yet and
that's the drama right
right kabang
wait starts to break they're shrieking
then it intensifies and kind of looks
like
maybe you two will be lost at sea
forever
for sure right and then i love
the aftermath soaking wet but happy
what are you gonna do that
that is so serious that's a great
wedding are you going to get it all
framed together that's fantastic
yeah we got to get them printed out and
just put them you know in some sort of
succession in a frame i think it would
be hilarious i just love that
the picture where i first see the waves
yeah i think i was about to be murdered
yes the way that i'm looking so scared
in that way which should have told my
wife
that i am not the person that's going to
be able to protect her
in our marriage yeah well she knows that
now she knows that now
it would have been great if you panicked
and pushed her in front of the wave
that you should have done yes i've
always thought that's what a spouse is
for
um broke our pack
we have a clip here from the movie
yesterday that you're in anything we
need to know about this
clip i know the premises of the film is
obviously
uh parents that give their kids
permission but pretty much to have
anything they want they get to call the
shots for 24 hours
with and then comedy ensues comedy
ensues yeah
this scene is with jennifer garner and
you know she
is awesome it was it was just cool to
get to do this
with her and uh i'm the cat i'm the
person that she
kind of tells that she's having this
really bad
moment as part of this day and i offer
up
uh some pretty solid advice in my
opinion i'm sure you do let's take a
look at this clip from yesterday
are you okay yeah i i just got into a
fight with my husband uh and you want me
to beat him up
no no nothing like that give him a
wedgie
no no it's just that today was the first
day in like a year where i felt like we
were really
in it together yeah and then he just had
to go and be a wuss
sounds like karen she's bad because i
took our life savings and bought a fleet
of ambulances and i barely know how to
drive this one
but you can't force people to change you
got to do what works for you
and he can either join the party or it's
his loss you know
that's so true not good advice really
yeah i love when people who clearly have
make terrible decisions give advice
that's my
it's my favorite part of life i offered
to beat up her husband
i you know whatever well she should have
just said yeah do that
yeah yesterday and give b give him a
wedgie then beat him up
um well yesterday will be available to
stream on netflix on friday
keenan returns to nbc march 16th man
this is insane
barb and star is available on demand new
episodes of the netflix after party will
be announced on netflix is a joke
and fortunes podcast sincerely fortune
is available wherever
you get your podcast enough already
fortune it's
it's insane conan if you need me to be a
part of your band
uh i've got some extra time i got no
bands so yes
yes yeah you can grab that guitar hey
fortune congratulations on everything
i'm really happy for you
and i look forward to seeing you in
person soon i appreciate it
so nice to talk to you conan all right
you take care
bye buddy